[Music]
we're gonna try all these different
flavors so we're gonna guess what they
are
it smells like a spice rack it smells
like a deli I don't know how I feel
about this okay like changes flavors
right they really nailed the Rye in the
sauerkraut flavor yeah there's like
cheese there's like this big cheese sour
cheese it does taste like a Reuben these
chips big first of all that's great oh
man that smells like fish that doesn't
taste like anything reminds me of an
Italian restaurant yeah it tastes like
an Italian restaurant tastes like pasta
chips we have to come you stop right
here I'm done these are brown these look
like it's gonna be a really strong
flavor yeah this chip like liquor to you
and like hardened it tastes kind of like
a salad to me there's like olives
there's like a pickle element of it
that's so good though almost too much
for a chip they all smell the same what
the head like mad now ranch
I thought with meat they taste like
upper-class sour cream and onion yeah
chips it tastes like grabbing it in full
of meat and putting it in your mouth
definitely a hint of gravy that pepper
yeah there's definitely pepper on it
there's something comforting about that
a little homey I think we both agree
that these are truffle right oh yeah
those would be exactly difficult
definitely the biscuits and gravy here
we're right this is our guest right
are you kidding me no not a chance in
hell yeah you're telling me that this is
how it should go
I'm gonna stare at this one and god damn
it you're right I think this might be my
favorite the biscuits and gravy no baby
no wrong to tell about their choice is
wrong I think it's pretty apparent which
one's the favorite I feel like we live
in the future and that you can eat a
sandwich in chip form oh I wish Lay's
would just make bags of meat if tasted
like other things like it's right like
leave the potato behind Lay's just give
us roast beef it tastes like chicken
Oh fun